embrace who you are whatever problem
you're facing right now in your business
think about who you are as a person and
and the message you want to spread as a
company and try to turn that challenge
you're facing that weakness of yours and
make it into a strength this comes as a
result from one of my youtube viewers
love you guys
rolling eight who wrote in to say hi I
have a question I'm a college student
making minimum wage so my funds are low
I'm working at creating the food product
for sale I want to start small it's a
great idea so far it's been difficult to
find businesses which will take orders
with labels and packaging in less than
20k and who do not charge extremely high
prices do you have advice on how to find
a business we'll take a smaller order
and not charge me as high price thanks
so much here's the thing ok you could go
and you could try to use the AMA I'm a
small business angle I'm gonna grow with
you and and some businesses will will go
with that it'll give you a cheaper deal
I think the real solution for you is to
embrace who you are so I don't know what
it is that you stand for but if it's a
it's a college student thing ok what I
would do is say proudly made by a
college student or proudly made by Jim
and hang print the labels because people
like supporting the little guy your
product has to be good ok it has to be
good if you want referrals if you want
people to buy repeat orders from you but
there's nothing wrong with saying you're
a small business and be proud of that
and print your own labels I'm not gonna
be part of your story on the website you
say nobody would take our deal for less
than 20,000 orders so we had to print
our own labels turn it into a strength I
would support that company because
people like believing in the underdog
and they hate the big corporations and
they want to see small businesses be
successful so turn that weakness of
yours and make it into something
powerful for you now if you if family is
a
part of of your life and part of the
message you want to spread maybe you
have your five-year-old niece draw
something on the label think of ways to
make it creative there's nothing wrong
with printing it yourself and using that
story and leveraging it so people want
to buy more because it's a homemade
label people will buy more if you tell
the story properly so stop trying to be
the big guy and think about how you can
embrace who you really are to your
advantage and bringing more deals and be
happier believe for those who are
watching like the video give it a thumbs
up below it always makes you want to do
more for you and let me know what you
think leave a comment if you haven't
left a comment yet in the video please
leave a comment
I love seeing those come in that's what
really makes me want to do more videos
for you so leave a comment you have a
question put it below thank you so much
and I'll see you soon